[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
Ted not to do this monologue because I
want to hear this story about Joe
DeVito's mirror being stolen but if I
don't then I can't use this
so you're gonna tell that story all
right happy Monday everyone I'm sorry he
may not be Jack Kennedy he's better a
jacked Kennedy okay
let's go
oh yeah oh man
yeah almost as ripped as me
that's obviously the Democratic
presidential hopeful RFK Jr looking less
like a politician and more like the king
of late night
over the weekend he posted this video
with the caption getting in shape for my
debates with President Biden
meanwhile here's Biden getting ready for
the same debates
[Applause]
yeah well right now RFK Jr is the only
presidential candidate whose poll
numbers are actually higher than his
body fat
all right
of course
I mean the competition isn't exactly
Fierce the last time Chris Christie took
his shirt off Greenpeace tried to roll
it back in the water
sorry about that
governor and Gavin Newsom here's his
workout
so you get it RFK Jr is indeed different
he's the most muscular Kennedy family
member since Arnold bench pressed the
maid
anyway RFK Juniors almost 70 which shows
you that people age differently some
look like this at 70 and some look like
this at any age
[Music]
but RFK comes at a time when America
needs it most we're bouncing back from
the pandemic and we do mean bouncing the
average American who gained weight
during the pandemic gained roughly 29
pounds during the lockdowns I couldn't
believe that number either until I
realized who threw off the average
but I know 29 pounds or as they call it
in Europe two and a half cat Temps
but RFK Jr tweeted that as president
he'll push us to exercise eat well and
fortify our immune system where it
sounds hopeless and terrible let's face
it we're a fat country we love it
still I can get behind it because
working out is one of the few things you
can do yourself that incentivizes hard
effort and brings success it's not like
picking stocks or betting on horses or
having your dad hook you up with a gig
on an oil company board of directors
we're not talking about luck here you
get out what you put in you lift weights
and the mirror says well done it's why
so many young kids avoid trouble when I
get them to join a gym of course the gym
is in my basement but you get my points
there's just no relation replacement for
exercise well doing blow and drinking
nothing but coffee is a close second but
that's neither here nor there you work
out for real you get an enviable
physique just like RFK Juniors or even
mine
don't laugh you should see me in a
girl's small T-shirt
take it from me
because I work out every day
[Applause]
you know
I could go for some push-ups
right away Mr Gutfeld
[Applause]
RFK Jr is smart he's not trashing
Biden's Health but filming his workouts
that allow you to trash him yourself by
making the comparison between Captain
ripped and the old fella currently
putting socks over his shoes
and he's also questioning many of the
democratic orthodoxies which is why he
has more enemies than Andrew Cuomo at a
nursing home just days after RFK did a
podcast with Joe Rogan where he voiced
his views on the vaccine a camera
chasing MD named Dr Hotes attacked them
both calling the podcast misinformation
nonsense and just awful he said this you
know because he's an expert in health
well did we show you who this expert is
foreign
and here's a reminder of RFK Jr
here's a side by side so who's the
expert in health
no wonder when Hotes was invited to
debate RFK he turned it down like it was
a free gym membership
now I wouldn't mind having a President
Who pumps iron who has that discipline
after all he's not on Twitter all day or
hanging out at Black Tie Affairs the guy
hikes he boats he lifts he hunts who
knew that the most rounded candidate was
also the most cut
and imagine if he wins the White House
how would this guy or even this guy
compared to this
if nothing else that's got to be better
than this
I don't know if he actually be a good
president who knows but he can't be
worse I mean from what I've seen he's
sort of an OG damn not hyper woke and
rfk's built up his guns while Biden's
coming for yours
you like that huh
and he's willing to question everything
who does that remind you of right he's a
little like the guy who came down that
escalator six years ago the only
difference he'll probably take the
stairs
[Applause]
cheese grilled the more witnesses than
Jeffrey Dahmer oh so the True Crime
podcast on Fox Family
these set the North American land speed
record for getting a sunburn Fox News
contributor Tom
he may be a comedian but he gets more
laughs as a father actor writer comedian
Jamie listen
our show's moving to 10 p.m but we're
still telling her it's at 11.
Fox News contributor
Jamie we point out to our viewers our
new viewers that you live in Alaska so
how do you keep in shape there do you
lift Igloo blocks it's hard to like the
other day I was at the gym in my friend
was like oh we should do abs and I was
like no what it's going to take so much
for someone to even see him yeah like
why would we bother no one will leave it
so it's very hard to stay in shape
because you're all layered up you know
oh yeah because you're in Alaska yeah
and it's like so you don't bother but I
was watching the videos I love the
greatest hits of bidenfone he's like the
first president we've ever had were you
where you have a favorite fall yes
yeah and he was making fun of this RFK
video RFK looks great he did nine
push-ups and Biden was like man when I
fall on my face I have people that lift
me up
his reps came out by interrupts came out
and said he can actually do like he'll
do one to two pull-ups if he's at a
dinner and the bathroom's far away
[Laughter]
he has a morning routine Biden has a
morning routine I heard he does like one
set of where am I's
and um
that goes the president's bedroom and
he's like we better get out of here
before he gets back
he got four out of there so Emily I'm
going to ask you to forego your comments
on the story and tell me what the hell
is going on with Joe DeVito to keep it
fast what happened what's going on it's
an ongoing investigation I can't comment
but I can tell you the rest of the
commercial break no but his very
important mirror went missing and mirror
yes and there's security footage I'll
leave it at that security footage that
somebody stole his mirror do we know who
the person is
it's being investigated wait just tell
me is it somebody we know does it rhyme
with schmill Mead
probably gonna end up being Jesse Waters
yeah yes
yeah you can't walk by a mirror without
either looking at it or taking it uh
uh well this will uh RFK Junior's
physique influence how you vote you
being of course a woman with very
shallow instincts
a sexist would say I don't even say that
anymore
Mr 10 p.m already all right
um I what intrigued me about this is the
fact that already there's been over 14
million views soon to be close to 15
million and we also in the same week
have learned that almost 7 out of 10
Americans think that Biden is not
physically and mentally capable of being
a president here he's coming out making
a good point everyone gained 100 pounds
during covid let's get back in shape he
talked about inflation he's talking
about essentially let's get back to
normal human inflation because right now
everyone is blown up literally and
figuratively and he is tired of it
um and you contrast that with the really
dismissive nature of the Democrat Party
right people dared to ask Pelosi about
people's questions about his mental
competency reporter did and she said
don't bother me with that filth that's
not worth it that's ridiculous Newsweek
called him uh Fringe Esquire called him
RFK a junior a crackpot called him right
wing said he would be cannon fodder if
he goes up to debate Biden but the
reality is that he is double digits more
than his body fat percentage rating with
the Democrat Party so the fact that the
establishment and the leadership right
now is ignoring him casting him away
dismissing him means that as always they
are ignoring what Americans are telling
them which is that they want anyone but
Biden that yes he is a viable fantastic
candidate because he is anyone but Biden
and he has the good of the country in
mind unlike Biden who doesn't have
anything in mind ah Tommy
[Applause]
how do you stay in shape I've noticed
you know I've noticed you I I do I mean
I'll look at you calisthenics Greg I
look at you when you're not looking and
I'll I'll go how does he how does he say
so trim Greg I do think that that was a
great observation about Trump he is the
Trump of this election because he's
being himself he's getting Free Press by
just and he's not doing it in a
manipulative way he's doing because he's
he's on The Cutting Edge he's doing
exactly what he believes and then he
does things like this like the guy
actually does push-ups so he takes off a
shirt and he does a bunch of push-ups
and it's getting tons of views and the
Press is treating him like Trump They're
laughing at him and they're saying he
has no chance in the upcoming elections
I've seen articles that say there is no
chance that this science denier will
ever be president well he's now getting
support on the left but also on the
right yeah I know a lot of right Wingers
who really like this guy because of his
medical Freedom stance he's better on
medical freedom than most people on the
right I think that's a sad thing but
it's also good for the realignment of
the country Trump realigned the country
he got a lot of blue-collar workers to
come over to the Republican side uh JFK
RFK Jr is probably going to do the same
thing with people who believe in Freedom
no
he could always run as an independent
and like actually win by pulling the
left and the right to his side and
they're more independent voters as you
can tell I'm on the five
some uh some commentary I heard earlier
cat you know when you look at him do you
think that it's all natural do you think
that he's might be doing some stuff like
maybe mixing a little testosterone with
ozempic with them with a steroidal
floater
no it sounds like his business yeah
that's true yeah I mean so RFK Jr has
said some truly unhinged stuff over the
years truly unhinged but the thing is
people tend to overlook that when
they're looking for a rebound guy yes
which is exactly what this is right yeah
people are like okay they're over biting
this guy is hot he's younger he has abs
you know it's exact because they're like
okay you know he's a little crazy he's a
little wild but it's a lot different
from this boring guy who eats vanilla
ice cream and goes to bed at 4 pm he's a
bad boy this is exactly like when
Kardashian started dating Pete Davidson
yes exactly
exactly I think it is but yeah the bad
boy Kennedy's back in town nobody's like
oh it's my rebound guy sane enough who
wants that no you want a Kennedy you
want to get in the back of a Harley and
have your hair blowing in the wind you
want me smoking a cancer stick standing
over the body of a Drifter yeah
that doesn't Greg you've inspired me yes
there we go do it do it Tommy
you can do it Tommy nice yes don't stop
hey don't stop Tommy keep going Tommy
keeper Don't Stop Don't Stop
don't stop
there you go
nicely done see yeah
all of you
all of you saw what I had seen before
all right before we go that's beautiful
I was impressed and then worried yeah me
too I was kind of I was wondering if he
would do it until death yeah
all right before we go tickets are
available for my upcoming book tour with
special guest Mr Fitness himself Tom
shallou will be in Clear Water Fort
Myers Providence and Reading
Pennsylvania home of the peanut bar
check out this preview I love saying
that all right
[Applause]
great
ly
well it feels a little stale
[Music]
go to gutfeld.com for tickets before
it's too late
I don't know what that's cryptic we're
gonna kill all of you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else